on social media david is halloween we
want to let you know that right now the
neo museum saying that it will be closed
for the evening so if you are watching
us maybe from one of the hotel rooms on
the strip beware of that certainly not a
great afternoon to be outside we talk
about those groups those sensitive
groups who should stay indoors close
your windows when these dust storms
happen talking about children older
adults plus people who may have some
breathing issues and i want to show you
this video from earlier today you can
just see how much dust is in the air
here the camera's shaking this is a time
lapse from prim earlier today see the
traffic there slowing down as that dust
cloud comes through again we sped this
up for you let's talk about outages
right now not many power outages
affecting customers for nd energy here
in southern nevada right now the entire
system just ticked up to about 5 000
customers without power and if we look
in a little closer here to our area
about 211 customers so that is not
anything like we've seen before but
certainly if your power goes out and you
have a generator at your house you want
to run that generator outside to avoid
any carbon monoxide poisoning another
issue to tell you about here us-93
that is the highway that runs from here
to kingman down to phoenix
that road is closed from kingman south
there was a crash one person has died
we're going to get you more information
on that but right now u.s 93 from
kingman south to phoenix is closed and
christian kirsten as you know that is
the only way to get to phoenix in a
in a time timely way you could say so if
you know someone headed that way
certainly give them a heads up guys back
to you